I got our Martin Caesar here our second
top
right manufacturing rotation that's
great work show wish I could stay longer
it's great to be here and I'm going to
talk a little bit about these production
methods that are petros described
yesterday in the overview so the
starting point here is apparently by now
that established technique that I'm sure
most of you in the know know I'm gonna
describe it anyway because I don't want
to assume that everybody has seen this
but so there is this method that are
based on randomized projections for
computing your low-rank approximation to
matrix and what we've been working on
that quite a bit the last few years is
to see can some of these ideas be used
to compute full factorization so
matrices so say you have a matrix that's
in this case the assumption is not that
it's gigantic but it's large enough that
using existing methods would be
challenging to say tens of thousands
hundreds of thousands maybe millions of
jobs big computer we want to compute a
full factorization of it or perhaps you
want to compute the partial
factorization where the rank the
numerical rank is not tiny compared to
the matrix dimension so it's 10% of the
matrix or 50 or something like this what
do you do efficiently then and some of
these things will also lead to other
poor implementations for for really the
basic low-rank approximation again for
the case for the rank is not that low
and some of the main things here are how
to use randomization to to minimize
communication it's the idea to get
efficiency for most of these things is
that we want to cast the so all these
algorithms they spend a large number of
flops and flops have different costs and
the cheapest ones we know are pretty
much in this context our a matrix matrix
multiplications so if I can take any of
these matrix algorithms and I can cast
it so that I spend the vast majority on
processing large chunks of matrix then
typically I get high performance and
this gets particularly important if you
do things like GPU computing the matrix
is stored on a hard drive anything like
this so I should say here when I say
that an algorithm is blocked then this
is in con
- to vet to matrices to algorithms that
proceed by a sequence of matrix vector
operations so classical column pivoted
QR would be an archetypical one okay so
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna start by
just briefly reviewing this randomized
SVD and then talk about how to
generalize it to fool so the randomized
as we did for the case when K is small
when the rank is small so I'll go a
little bit fast because I assume that
most of you have seen this some a not
have so they set up is this I'm given a
matrix a for bid motor size they might
fit in RAM and Mike north to might be
sparse it might be dense and the only
assumption on the matrix is really that
it has no numerical rank but it's its
singular values decay some sort of
decays that it makes sense to
approximated by a right K matrix or K in
this case is substantially smaller than
the matrix dimensions and I want to
compute an approximate factorization
where u and V are very thin matrices
like this D is a small diagonal matrix
and my objective is to have this product
be close to a so that the norm of the
difference there is small as opposed to
having very high relative accuracy on
all the eigenvectors needler vectors and
the algorithm that we proposed for doing
this looks like this you draw at orphan
Gaussian random matrix R I multiply them
together to four words we form a
sampling matrix Y that's also to one
thin so each column of Y is a random
linear combination of the columns of a
and then the claim is that if you look
at the space spanned by the columns of Y
then this forms a recently if it
captures the space spanned by the
dominant left singular vectors away so
it's a reasonably good basis for the
column space of a reasonably close to
optimal with one caveat and it's that
you need to draw a few extra vectors and
the the key thing that comes out of both
numerical experiments and out of the
theory is that the number of over
sampling you need to do is quite
if you drew or five or ten extra samples
then you already can with very high pool
bill to say that you're close to the
optimal at least for the case or the
singular values DJ reasonably fast okay
so that's the function of the sample
matrix Y so now what you do is you were
to normalize these columns you have a
set of spanning vectors but they're
typically clustered or what long the
directions of the dominant singular
vectors so you need towards the
normalized them who gets an orthonormal
basis if I found project the columns of
a down to that basis you get this matrix
B which now is shaped like this I do
dense s-video B and now you just project
back up so this is the or SVD so this is
the starting point this has been around
for you know 15 years or something
so the question now is how and I should
say before I move on to to the next case
so it's really the one of the main
advantages of this method is that you
only interact with a through the matrix
matrix multiplied so this typically
gives lower accuracy than the Credo
method would do how do you measure
accuracy in your context so there so for
instance the question is how good or the
the diagonal entries of d how good
approximations are they to the singular
vectors if I use the SVD as a low-rank
approximation how well does I compare it
to the space you would get by optimizing
in the krilov subspace so in the curl of
subspace if you sort with a single
vector u you can access in this case the
case power of a which when you look at
accuracy
right something so it's so here I'm the
purpose of this logarithm ourselves to
minimize the norm between a the
difference between a product right but
certainly if you can apply higher powers
of eight you will do better on that
metric basically and it basically in
regards to any question you might ask in
terms of the quality the critical method
will do better than this but if you
think keep fixed the number of matrix
vector multiplies but the point here is
that all the interaction is through a
matrix matrix multiplied like this you
can even reformulate this so that you
only see the matrix and once you can
sort of do both of these in a single
pass or they mate the matrix so you
don't need to store the matrix that also
you can make it extremely communication
efficient and this is really the key to
the high computational efficiency we've
seen so the question I want to talk
about in this talk is what what what if
K is not much smaller what if the rank
is not much smaller than the slices per
dimension so you want all the think it
over bad news there's something like
this well in principle you could have
some coarse just set k equal to n in
this algorithm but this would be kind of
e named because then the matrix D would
not be small anymore it'd be the same
size that's a and you would have to
solve exactly the same problem you set
out to do so the natural way to do this
the most immediate extension of the
randomized as we did to the case of
computing a full matrix factorization if
it appears for instance in a paper by
Demerol and de metrio and holds from
2007 and it looks like this so you drew
in this case a square Gaussian matrix so
special matrix you just were so
normalized its columns and that forms
your right factorization so in this case
we're looking for not so I've made one
softening of my requirements so now I
don't require the middle matrix here to
be diagonal I accept the triangular
matrix in the middle so U and V should
be unitary I allow a triangular matrix
in the middle but I still want it to be
ranked revealing in the sense that if I
truncate this factorization to the K
dominant terms the Mac should give me
rank K approximation that's
study close to the optimal one so that's
the game of play I'm giving up on
tagging ality of the middle factory and
my case this is a very natural extension
of the randomizer CD so in this case so
I get a square Y matrix they were to
normalize the columns and I get sort of
hard distributed unitary matrix here now
you start as the right factor in the
factorization amanah just computes an
arm pivoted QR factorization of 8 times
2b and this this is it so it's an
extremely simple thing to compute there
are I suppose there's only one matrix
matrix multiply and to UM pivoted QR
factorizations okay so this is provably
right revealing as it turns out you can
work through the analysis and you start
looking at what if I look at the first K
columns of V then that sort of looks
like a sorting Gaussian matrix so the so
the first K columns of a times three it
sort of is like the matrix Y in the or
SVD and so on so for small K it's very
similar conceptually and in some ways
it's a silly algorithm because it takes
a lot of flops but the key is that
everything here is very very fast on
modern processors so I think demo
starting points in investigating these
things was looking at things like it's
trust and matrix-matrix multiply so this
course these algorithms for computing
two matrices that are faster than cubic
complexity and they showed that you can
do this in a perfectly stable way and
then if you can do the matrix matrix
multiplied fast you can also do on
pivoted QR factorization very fast and
stately and then the points here but all
the things you could easily do if you
have stress and do they do not really
around at all it doesn't get you to the
spectrum structural matrix but that is
what this the option matrix does so if
you introduce this randomization then
you get something that's proved a right
revealing and you can do it in
complexity
whatever it is 2.8
so it's rank revealing in a very weak
sense their theorem is very very weak it
involves a gap in the spectrum well I
suppose minx did as well but his
estimates are much sharper I'll show you
the miracle experiments that will
illustrate the one so in this talk I
don't use the technical definition of
rank of the Junge so there's this
definition that the discrepancy between
the exact singular value and the balance
you get should grow with most polynomial
a yes to make exercise increases in this
kind of stuff that's not what I mean
when I say rank we're dealing I used the
term in a new formal sense okay so this
works fine and it turns out that if you
run this on a just modern computer on a
normal computer it will run much faster
than confident you are even though there
are much more flops so there is some
interest to this method and if you want
to get better accuracy you can do this
slight modification that I'd be curious
to see if somebody has seen this because
it's very simple idea I'm not claiming
originality but it turns out that if you
just apply a a couple times to G before
you do this algorithm then you actually
get extremely good rank revealing
properties yeah yes but combining it
with the random matrix G yes no it's not
a square of G it's a square of a so I
replied yes GU squared yes yes I just
miss her right so in any case and if you
do this on a GPU then this operation is
free applying a to square matrix costs
so you could have done 8 to the 2qg but
instead you're doing a transpose E sorry
I don't assume that a is symmetric if a
is symmetric right H queen all right it
could take you power shopping oh it's
square only for notational simplicity
doesn't have to be spared
the method works whether a is square not
the squareness is purely for notational
simplicity okay so let's look at how
this works in practice so here's a very
simple example see I have a matrix is
singular values decay very fast they
decay exponentially fast they go all the
way down to double precision and the two
lines to your other bounds you get from
this very simple
randomizer of the algorithm that I
described so when you do a rank with
unique factorization you get a
triangular matrix you want to say so the
key thing to the value of the top left K
by K block provides one side bound
that's a lower bound for the K singular
value if you look at the largest
singular value or the bottom right block
than that the other one so you get two
estimates that sandwich the exact
singular value and in this case it all
looks very nice but the point is that in
this case basically anything you do will
work well should you call them pivot eqr
it does even slightly better it's snow
we're actually but it does a little bit
better and if you use just a couple
steps of power iterations you're
basically nail those singular values
exactly is it slightly more challenging
example the singular values to K more
slowly here is the this simplistic you
are the algorithm that's calling
pavilack you are and that's what you do
yet if you just apply a couple of powers
from a first here okay you control the
spectrum copy us left and right secret
vectors run your construction of the
English majors oh yes yes my test matrix
R is random but it it really doesn't
matter in this case it's basically
rotational America so it's only depends
on yeah when you called when you're
elected members for the small singular
wage this looks nice because in the
iPhone when the singular values becomes
small what happened to the relative
arrows will return to that so this is
actually not the algorithm I'm proposing
that this is a warm-up it's a very
simple example to illustrate the
concepts well we look at the relative
errors in a little bit
so the column pivoted QR looks very
different for other matrices I'll show
an example in a bit for the randomized
methods it doesn't really matter it's
only the singular values here's another
example it's the same story okay so
here's the method that I'm so I'm going
to describe a method that can be
interrupted that sort of much more
similar to traditional methods that
you've seen so the first one was just a
way of illustrating the concepts so what
I want is I want the factorization where
u and V are unitary the middle matrix T
should be triangular in this case I
choose upper triangular it's natural
when the matrix looks like this which is
the case I'm looking at and I want it to
be right revealing so in particular I
want as I said truncations of this to be
close to optimal right key
approximations and I'm also going to be
a little bit greedy I'm gonna want the
diagonal element so T to be very good
approximations to the singular values
all right this sometimes happens and
it's very nice to get a lot of stuff for
free so as an overview this what I'm
going to describe it so it's a blocked
algorithm so you choose the block size
which is purely computational tuning
parameter it's if you run this on a
computer like this you should think of
the block size as being maybe 100 if you
do another poor computation you should
think of it as being a couple thousands
should do it on a big distributed
machine diagnosis it's a it's a
complicated optimization problem take
the best block size
though the idea is I start with the
matrix a and now I'm going to behave
just like textbook then your algebra
text you lie householder transformations
in this case I'm applying them both from
the left and the right the ones I fly
from the right their function is to move
it as much of the weights as possible
into the first columns then when I have
when I place as much weight as I can in
the leftmost columns then I just apply
householder transformations from the
left to make the matrix upper triangular
so you do this one after another so this
is exactly the pattern old phrases
column pivoted you are in which case you
apply
permutation matrices from the right so
that's more restrictive and again how
sort of effectors
the last okay that's the trick here
though it's been an open question in
numerical linear algebra for a long time
it's how do you find groups of these
transformations you know there are many
different ways of finding one vector at
a time to do this but how do you group
them and find and of course this is
exactly what randomization is the
extremely good at so let's be a little
bit more precise if we look at the first
step in this cartoon that I did in the
last once I have a block slice B so this
is the first step so I want to find two
unitary matrices U and V and I've looked
them so these are the first B columns
here the first three columns of U and
this leads me to a matrix with a little
B by B leading top left entry so what I
want to do here is I want to find U and
V that squeezed as much mass as possible
into t1 one a man of whatever I couldn't
get into t1 one I want that to be
located in c2 to so t1 two should be it
should ideally be zero that'd be very
computation expensives I tolerate as
long as it's small in magnitude
I'm fine with that okay so the optimal
choice would need to have if I could
hypothetically find a set of B vectors
in V one who span exactly aligns with
the span of the dominant left singular
vectors of a then everything would be
perfect in that case that would
precisely optimize here at c1 two would
be exactly zero and everything would
work view but this turns out to be
exactly what the randomized SVD is very
good at the key randomized step in the
randomized SVD is to find a basis but
almost aligns with the span of the top
left singular vectors so that's exactly
what I'm doing
so in order to find this transformation
matrix V I do exactly as before I draw a
tall thin joshan matrix I apply a to it
a couple times so think of here as being
either zero or one or two it's not large
it's just a couple of applications away
so I get my sample matrix Y and then
what I do is I just drive Y to wrap your
triangular forms I find the B how
sort of transformations that drive why
two upper triangular form and that forms
my matrix so VD here it's a law it's a
it's a square unitary matrix but it was
a very compact representation its
identity plus a ranking it right be
matrix so it can be applied very rapidly
it can be stored efficiently and so on
okay so this is basically the key idea
is this is algorithmically we're done
now it's just a matter of looking at how
this works okay so now whether it's one
slight twist that I haven't told you
about
so actually what I'm doing is in
addition to this business or finding the
householder vectors I also compute two
small SVD of the diagonal block and
rotate this block accordingly so that's
just to really get the singular values
on the diagonal because I remember the
block size is fairly small it's a
hundred or a thousand or something so
computing your small exact last video
that it's basically for free though it
could cost you nothing and it's very
helpful okay so this is the method you
get at the end I'm just claiming I'm
going to show you numerical examples
you're not going to see any theorems so
this talk is very sort of proceeds in
parallel with Ning's talk from yesterday
except that he was was very rigorous
with his theory here there's no theory
that our going I'm telling you a little
bit more about what happens agree with
me okay so I'm gonna end up getting the
singular values on the diagonal I claim
or very good approximations up here I'm
gonna get nonzero entries but they're
gonna be very small but your video size
10 to the minus 2 10 to the minus 5
we're just a very small number of power
iterations okay so let's look at this
numerically so here is a matrix again
that has pretty fast decay of the
singular values so exponential decay and
it's not official matrix it's I
generated using this randomized
technique so we have I compared to
quantum pivot if you are that's the
magenta line the green line is the
method that Ming described we apply
column publique you are twice the
daughters
to improve things a lot but it turns out
to be fairly expensive unless you use
the randomized called pivot your it's
called a pivot EQ or it turns out to be
very expensive in this context so and
here we show relative errors so
basically the UTV with no power
iteration is essentially the same
accuracy of Stuart's QoP algorithm which
is actually very good for many purposes
that's perfectly good enough and if you
use a couple extra power iterations to
drive the error to be very small and in
this case at least in this case we have
exponential decay it does look like
we're controlling the relative error
very well here is the more challenging
case I have very slow decay of the
singular values initially done very fast
and the nasty old tail that's gonna
pollute things so this is sort of the
nastiest example we see and even here it
works very well so you lose a little bit
of accuracy right around this sharp
drop-off but for the most part it works
very well here it's not here it's the
real example this is a discretized
boundary into equation so we see
relatively slow decay of the singular
values and in this case the randomized
method behaves exactly as you would
predict it's based on the examples
you've seen but the difference is that
column pivot if you are in our behaves
very very differently because now the
columns actually have specific meaning
so you sort of exhaust there are sort of
subspaces you can assign you need to or
so it's called pivot eqr behaves very
differently but the randomized methods
are basically agnostic to ten fifteen
twenty percent right but these are weird
relative barrels this is Sigma k plus
one over some other signal older
spectacles I measure the error compared
to the Sigma heat loss Lumbees I stop
you have in the denominator it's this
distance divided by the single body
okay so the final numerical experiment I
went to show was I claimed that the
diagonal entries turn out to be good
approximation so the singular values
well how good so let's look at this so
this is where the two steps of power
iterations I apply a transpose twice
when I generate the matrices and then
the red line again or the singular
values the blue line these are the
diagonal entries to get from the column
pivoted QR which some sort of proxy for
the singular values but it's known to be
pretty bad but Stewart's your PR rhythm
is known to give fairly good
approximation for the singular values in
this regard and it was much better but
the utility is much better still
so you basically don't see the black
line which is the diagonal entries for
the utility because it's exactly
underneath the red one here is the
challenging example and now the black
line sort of escapes a little bit right
there but they're pretty much spot-on
and here's another couple examples let's
look at computational timings so I'll
show you the exotic timings here so this
is on a 14 core machine so we compare
against to the MTL implementations of la
pack so this is SVD here is : Peabody QR
and this is you t v-- wade through power
iterations so it's really much faster
than even quantum leakers usually column
pivot eqr it's oftentimes used as a
poor-man's as we did we really want the
SVD you want to have rank revealing but
it's considered too expensive but in
this case you can actually do something
that's much faster and has the same
advantage just : pivot EQ or and that
you can stop it if you give it an
accuracy say you want to have 5%
relative accuracy then quantum pivot eqr
has the beautiful property that you can
just stop you have the residual sitting
there you can stop then utility has
exactly the same property so this is for
in core and then the thing that I really
like about this slide here's the matrix
that's stored on a hard drive and we
maintain basically the same speed all
the way up to
mm by a hundred thousand for a fourteen
core machine so it's not I'm not playing
a trick that I'm using very underpowered
CPU it's a very good CPU and we just
still feed it from the matrix is stored
on a hard drive and again you could stop
this if you wanted to
here is a distributed memory
implementation so 96 course we have SVD
we have : p vq r and this is UT v and i
compare just like we did yesterday so
the gold standard here is on pivoted QR
so this parallel ice is very well on
it's often used as a reference it's not
quite as easy as matrix make just
multiply that sort of Pacifica cheat but
I'm Peabody QR is sort of the best you
could hope for for any non-trivial
numerical algorithm and we're getting
reasonably close to that here is on a
GPU so we're comparing you down
state-of-the-art implementations of SVG
and that's calling people to QR and this
is very frustrating to me because you
had shown this slide nine months ago
then : pivot EQ or at that point was up
here so it's a very easy business to be
in because it's extremely dependent on
if you have high quality programmers who
can put in a lot of time then these
things can change and most of these
examples some of them are done by a
collaborator of mine in Spain and I mean
he's very good but it's just him he does
it's not a big team it's just one guy
who has a little time here and there and
some of them are done by my graduate
student there's no formal training in
HPC so it's a very simple argument to
implement so this is the GPU
implementation and in particular here I
want to point out the there's basically
no difference in applying higher powers
because applying a tour so I'll be
basically for free energy for you it
it's it's absurdly cheap so you can get
very high accuracy out of this method
okay I think we are at noon but I think
we started two minutes late yeah okay
sorry if somebody needs to sneak off I
won't take offense but I just wanted to
mention that this
same ideas can be applied to do : pivot
EQ are as well so I've sort of been
saying if you trying to con people EQ or
slow your TV as fast it turns out to not
be quite true anymore it was true three
years ago or we figured out how to do
block pivoting using randomization as
well and these ideas they're so similar
to the UTP that I think even with just a
couple minutes I can get the main idea
across so the idea is basically the same
so I want to look an algorithm that
drives a matrix or triangular form in
such a way that it's sort of ranked with
the only I want to choose I want to have
the first sets of K columns the
reasonably good basis for the column
space so the traditional method here is
to do column pivoting you pick the
largest column you put it on the first
you also normalize everything with
respect to that one you pick the largest
one that remains and the problem there
is that it's really inherently a
sequence of matrix vector operations and
a lot of effort has been put into trying
to block this and I'll show you how it
can be blocked so again I'm looking at
the first step so how do you find a
bunch of unit vector so you want to find
a hundred pivot vectors at once so this
is exactly this problem that comes up in
C or it's finding the best subset of
vectors to form a basis and the the
algorithm that we have found works very
well it's a randomized one so you take a
and in this case I used my random matrix
like this I project the rows down there
for random linear combinations of the
rows of a it's a form of sampling matrix
Y and then I apply just basic column
pivot eqr to the columns of Y and Y is
very small it today's you pick B here to
be small enough that Y fits in cache so
you can do these very communication
intensive things on Y so I apply corn
and pivot eqr to Y and then that pigs
columns that turn out to be extremely
good pivot in columns and here there's a
very funny thing so the randomization it
turns out to be very reliable when the
singular values to tell you at badly in
my case you get very accurate why the
penances between the columns of Y are
very similar to the dependencies between
the columns of a but the randomization
says I'd be very unreliable in the case
for the singular values are flat in my
choice you're basically picking random
pivot columns they have no relationship
to the pivot columns you would pick from
here but in that case it doesn't matter
any columns or good pivot columns and
there is no regime where the spectrum is
flat so these are the two extreme
appoints you have one point where the
randomization messes up with everything
but in that case it doesn't matter any
choice is good the other one choosing
the right ones is critical but the
randomization almost surely makes you
find the right one and then what I've
been trying to prove
and I think meaning has been much more
successful at this is that you can sort
of interpret it very nicely between
these two that nothing bad happens in
the intermediate regime all right so
that's how it works this is the speedups
we're getting against and KL this is on
between 1 and 14 course we're about a
factor 5 faster and as matrices gets
larger as you add course things into the
moving in our direction some very
optimistic about this and Ming and
Giulio mangu and a number of people are
looking at working this into la Banque
so this was yeah here is an
implementation with GPU and just
illustrates the difference between
working on a hard drive and a
solid-state drive was the advance of
solid-state drives is very advantageous
to us in this environments because they
behave exactly the ways we need them to
behave these high-performance ok I am
this just my last little cartoon so used
to be for purposes of low-rank
approximation or the choice between us V
D which was optimal but very expensive :
pivot EQ are now we have randomized :
people to cure which is basically
exactly the same quality : pathetic you
are
whereas much faster and we have this
algorithm ran due to the that combines
really the best properties of everything
else
so in many cases and data Sciences and
remember that the off-diagonal entries
are size 10 to the minus 5 or something
so it really doesn't matter the output
is basically honest with it for many
practical purposes and here are some
papers some references we have code so
this is multi-core the outer core and
the GPU implementations are not quite
ready to be shared that's working
progress but the multi-core wants are
all done so thank you very much for
attention yes yes so in sum so as long
as the rank so when you apply this to
sparse matrix then we have to be in the
regime where the rank is much smaller
because the U and V vectors will be
dense
so it really only makes sense from the
right is small in that case everything
works the same exactly you don't apply
the updates to the matrix so you can do
those implicitly so birds if you in the
lingo or when you're out where you're
left looking and right looking are bonus
whether you actually explicitly update
the columns whether you postpone them so
if you have a sparse matrix just don't
do the updating of it and everything
works fine but of course u and v will be
dense so at some point it's going to
start to get expensive
you're getting very high accuracy
convergence on this but if you started
getting lower accuracy convergence can't
get more about times is there a way to
play it out the other way right so in
this case the parameter so there are two
parameters that go in one is the block
size which is a performance parameter
the other one is is how many power
iterations you find and that one we
don't do it adaptively you tell in
advance and it's really based on how
much accuracy do you want you have some
sense of how fast the singular values
decay and basically you know if you try
to go and you find that's not accurate
enough if you start with zero and you
find that's not accurate enough you just
have to redo it we don't I don't have a
clever way of sort of detecting oh I
picked Q little too small maybe I should
go back and I can reuse things I'm just
saying you can be much more clever about
these things but we haven't gotten there
yet
[Applause]